selamat datang kembali di understanding Quantum information and computation, nama saya John Watus dan saya adalah direktur teknis untuk pendidikan di IBM Quantum
ini adalah pelajaran ke-13 dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran pertama di unit keempat dan terakhir yang membahas tentang Quantum error
correction Quantum Computing punya potensi untuk menghadirkan solusi yang efisien untuk tugas-tugas komputasi yang
algoritma klasik yang efisien belum diketahui dan mungkin memang tidak ada namun ada tantangan yang sangat besar yang
perlu diatasi jika kita ingin mengimplementasikan komputasi Quantum skala besar yang kita harapkan suatu hari nanti bisa
terwujud inti dari masalah ini adalah bahwa informasi Quantum sangat rapuh kamu bisa merusaknya hanya dengan
melihatnya dan oleh karena itu agar berfungsi dengan benar komputer quantum perlu mengisolasi informasi quantum yang mereka
simpan dari lingkungan sekitarnya secara ekstrem tapi di sisi lain komputer quantum itu sendiri harus memberi kita
kendali yang sangat presisi atas informasi Quantum ini dan itu mencakup inisialisasi yang tepat, operasi
uniter yang akurat dan andal, dan tentu saja kemampuan untuk melakukan pengukuran agar kita bisa mendapatkan hasil dari
komputasi jelas ada ketegangan di antara persyaratan-persyaratan ini dan di awal-awal Quantum Computing ada beberapa orang yang berpandangan bahwa kerapuhan
informasi quantum dan kerentanannya terhadap ketidakakuratan maupun noise lingkungan pada akhirnya akan
membuat Quantum Computing menjadi tidak mungkin hari ini hampir tidak ada keraguan bahwa membangun komputer
quantum skala besar yang akurat dan andal adalah tantangan yang sangat besar tapi kita punya alat kunci untuk membantu kita dalam upaya ini yang membuat kebanyakan
orang yang paham tentang bidang ini optimis bahwa Quantum Computing skala besar suatu hari nanti akan menjadi kenyataan dan alat itu adalah quantum error
correction untuk empat pelajaran berikutnya kita akan membahas Quantum error correction dengan fokus pada
hal-hal mendasar dalam pelajaran ini kita akan melihat pertama kali Quantum error correction termasuk salah satu yang pertama
kode koreksi error quantum yang ditemukan yaitu 9 qubit Shore code dan kita juga akan membahas konsep mendasar lain dalam Quantum
error correction yang dikenal sebagai diskretisasi error dalam pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya dari unit ini kita akan melihat konstruksi
kode koreksi error Quantum yang lebih canggih dan pada akhirnya lebih baik dan kita juga akan membahas masalah komputasi quantum pada informasi Quantum yang sudah di-encode menggunakan
komponen komputasi yang sendirinya tidak sempurna dan rentan terhadap error berikut adalah gambaran singkat tentang
pelajaran ini kita akan mulai dengan membahas kode repetisi klasik yang mungkin merupakan jenis yang paling sederhana dan paling dasar
dari kode koreksi error klasik kode repetisi klasik bukanlah kode yang sangat bagus menurut standar
teori pengkodean klasik setidaknya sendirinya tapi tidak apa-apa di sini kita mengutamakan kesederhanaan dan khususnya
kita akan melihat kode koreksi error klasik yang paling sederhana yang bisa kamu bayangkan yang kemudian akan kita gunakan sebagai dasar untuk contoh sederhana
dari kode koreksi error Quantum contoh itu adalah 9 qubit Shore code yang akan kita bahas secara mendetail
termasuk deskripsi kode itu sendiri serta prosedur untuk meng-encode qubit menggunakan kode ini mendeteksi error pada qubit yang sudah di-encode dan
mengoreksi error-error tersebut dan di bagian ketiga pelajaran ini kita akan membahas diskretisasi Error yang memungkinkan kita untuk memikirkan error arbitrary pada
qubit yang pada prinsipnya membentuk kontinum kemungkinan dalam istilah diskret pada intinya menyederhanakan error menjadi
apa yang disebut bit flip dan phase flip sebelum kita masuk ke detail teknis quantum error correction
ada baiknya kita meluangkan waktu sejenak untuk mempertimbangkan kebutuhan akan Quantum error correction maupun classical error
correction seperti yang saya singgung di awal pelajaran komputer quantum sangat rentan terhadap error karena
kerapuhan informasi quantum khususnya interaksi yang tidak diinginkan dengan lingkungan atau dengan kata lain
sisa dunia dapat mengganggu informasi Quantum interaksi yang tidak diinginkan ini dapat menyebabkan dekoherensi di mana informasi
pada dasarnya bocor ke lingkungan menyebabkan informasi yang disimpan oleh komputer quantum berperilaku semakin
klasikal sangat penting juga untuk menyadari bahwa operasi Quantum hanya bisa dilakukan dengan akurasi yang terbatas
misalnya kita mungkin ingin melakukan Quantum gate tertentu pada sebuah qubit tapi karena perangkat fisik tidak pernah
sempurna apa yang sebenarnya kita implementasikan mungkin hanyalah aproksimasi dari gate tersebut mungkin itu bukan masalah besar untuk
satu gate tapi jika niat kita adalah untuk melakukan ribuan atau jutaan quantum gate ketidakakuratan kecil ini akan
mulai terakumulasi dan ketika komputasi selesai kita bisa berakhir dengan state yang sangat berbeda dari yang kita
harapkan jadi ini adalah sumber error yang cukup berbeda tapi ini tentu saja sesuatu yang tidak bisa kita
abaikan orang-orang telah mempelajari kode koreksi error klasik selama hampir seabad dan kode-kode ini memiliki banyak aplikasi termasuk dalam
transmisi dan penyimpanan informasi tapi karena komponen komputasi klasik sangat andal kita sebenarnya tidak
membutuhkan koreksi error untuk membangun komputer klasik sekarang mungkin saja koreksi error sebenarnya tidak diperlukan
untuk membangun komputer quantum skala besar yang andal juga misalnya ide utama di balik Quantum
Computing topologi adalah bahwa mungkin saja membangun sistem Quantum yang kuat yang secara inheren terlindungi dari noise karena
sifat topologi dari sistem tersebut tapi kita tidak tahu apakah ini akan mungkin dan sudah cukup banyak yang percaya
bahwa koreksi error kemungkinan besar akan sangat penting dalam satu bentuk atau lainnya untuk Quantum Computing skala besar sekarang kita akan membahas kode repetisi
klasik yang menjadi dasar untuk kode koreksi error Quantum pertama kita yaitu 9 qubit Shore code yang
akan kita lihat sebentar lagi kode repetisi adalah contoh yang sangat dasar dari kode koreksi error
idenya adalah kita bisa melindungi bit dari error dengan hanya mengulangi setiap bit beberapa kali khususnya mari kita lihat
kode repetisi tiga-bit di sini kita meng-encode satu bit menjadi tiga dengan hanya mengulangi bit tersebut tiga kali jadi
nol di-encode sebagai 000 dan satu di-encode sebagai 111 tentu saja jika tidak ada yang salah
kita bisa membedakan dua kemungkinan tersebut dengan mudah tapi jika ada error dan salah satu bit terbalik katakanlah
artinya nol berubah menjadi satu atau satu berubah menjadi nol maka kita masih bisa mengetahui bit aslinya
dengan melihat nilai biner mana yang muncul dua kali secara setara kita bisa mendekode dengan menghitung nilai mayoritas
atau dengan kata lain nilai biner yang paling sering muncul dan tidak sulit untuk melihat bahwa
jika kita punya paling banyak satu bit flip error maka decoding akan benar tentu saja jika dua bit terbalik atau jika
ketiga bit terbalik maka tidak akan berhasil dan kita akan mendapatkan nilai yang salah saat mendekode dan itu adalah properti umum
yang dimiliki setiap kode koreksi error kamu mungkin bisa mengoreksi beberapa error tapi kamu tidak akan pernah bisa mengoreksi setiap error dan pada akhirnya ini
tentang mengurangi kemungkinan error bukan tentang menjamin kebenaran yang secara umum tidak
mungkin sebagai contoh situasi di mana kita bisa mengurangi kemungkinan membuat error misalkan
tujuan kita adalah untuk mengkomunikasikan satu bit kepada penerima hipotetis dan untuk melakukan itu kita bisa mengirimkan bit melalui
apa yang disebut binary symmetric channel yang membalik setiap bit yang dikirim melaluinya secara independen dengan beberapa probabilitas
P jadi dengan probabilitas 1 minus P penerima akan mendapatkan bit mana pun yang kita maksudkan untuk dikirim tapi dengan probabilitas P
bit terbalik dan penerima mendapatkan nilai yang berlawanan dari apa yang kita kirim jadi jika kita tidak menggunakan kode repetisi
dan sebagai gantinya kita hanya mengirimkan bit yang kita miliki melalui channel penerima akan mendapatkan bit yang salah dengan
probabilitas p di sisi lain jika kita terlebih dahulu meng-encode bit yang ingin kita kirim menggunakan kode repetisi tiga-bit dan
kemudian mengirimkan masing-masing dari ketiga bit encoding melalui channel maka masing-masing dari mereka terbalik dengan probabilitas P jadi
kemungkinan bit flip sekarang lebih besar karena ada tiga bit yang kemungkinan bisa terbalik bukan satu
tapi jika paling banyak satu bit yang terbalik maka penerima akan bisa mendekode dengan benar jadi kita hanya akan mendapatkan error setelah
decoding jika dua atau lebih bit terbalik selama transmisi dan tidak terlalu sulit untuk menghitung bahwa ini terjadi dengan
probabilitas 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P kubik untuk nilai P yang lebih kecil dari 1/12
ini menghasilkan penurunan probabilitas bahwa penerima berakhir dengan bit yang salah masih ada kemungkinan error dalam kasus ini tapi
kode mengurangi kemungkinan ini dan jika kamu ingin mengurangi kemungkinannya lebih jauh kamu bisa melakukan itu menggunakan
kode yang berbeda termasuk tapi tidak terbatas pada kemungkinan menggunakan kode repetisi di mana bit yang di-encode diulang
lebih dari tiga kali untuk nilai P yang lebih besar dari 1/12 ngomong-ngomong kode ini sebenarnya membuat
keadaan lebih buruk dalam artian meningkatkan kemungkinan bahwa penerima mendapatkan bit yang salah jadi kita tentu saja tidak akan menggunakan kode ini dalam
situasi tersebut kode repetisi tiga-bit adalah kode koreksi error klasik tapi kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan apa yang terjadi jika kita
coba menggunakannya untuk melindungi qubit dari error ini bukan kode koreksi error Quantum yang bagus seperti yang akan kita lihat
ia bisa mengoreksi beberapa error tapi membuat error lain lebih mungkin terjadi ia adalah langkah pertama menuju Shore
code jadi mari kita lihat cara kerjanya untuk qubit pertama-tama untuk lebih jelas ketika kita menyebut kode repetisi 3-bit yang digunakan
untuk qubit apa yang kita maksud adalah encoding sebuah qubit seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar di mana Alpha 0 plus beta 1 adalah
di-encode sebagai Alpha 000 plus beta 111 atau dengan kata lain state basis standar
diulang tiga kali perhatikan khususnya bahwa ini bukan hal yang sama dengan mengulangi state quantum tiga kali seperti pada
state quantum s yang di-encode sebagai s tensor s tensor s yang bukan encoding yang akan bisa kita
implementasikan untuk state Quantum s yang tidak diketahui berdasarkan teorema no-cloning encoding yang sedang kita bicarakan
di sisi lain sangat mudah diimplementasikan berikut adalah quantum circuit yang sangat sederhana yang melakukannya menggunakan dua qubit workspace yang diinisialisasi dan dua
controlled not gate sekarang misalkan sebuah error terjadi setelah encoding telah
dilakukan dan khususnya misalkan operasi poly x atau dengan kata lain bit flip terjadi pada salah satu
qubit dan dalam gambar ini adalah qubit di tengah tentu saja ini bukan satu-satunya jenis error yang bisa terjadi dan kamu mungkin
keberatan dengan ide bahwa error berbentuk operasi uniter yang sempurna ini tapi kita akan kembali ke ini nanti dalam pelajaran dan untuk sekarang kita bisa
hanya memikirkannya sebagai contoh berikut adalah state yang dihasilkan sama seperti encoding asli kecuali
bahwa bit di tengah dalam setiap K sudah dibalik jelas kita bisa melihat ini dari ekspresi matematis untuk state tersebut
tapi misalkan kita hanya memiliki tiga qubit dan kita curiga bahwa bit flip mungkin telah terjadi tapi kita tidak tahu qubit mana yang mungkin
terpengaruh salah satu cara untuk mengetahui apakah bit flip terjadi adalah dengan melakukan pengukuran basis standar dan memeriksa hasilnya dalam kasus ini kita akan melihat
baik 010 atau 110 dengan probabilitas bergantung pada Alpha dan beta dan dalam kedua kasus kesimpulan kita
adalah bahwa bit tengah terbalik tapi sayangnya itu merusak state Quantum asli dan state ini
mungkin sangat berharga bagi kita bagaimanapun seluruh intinya adalah untuk melindungi state Quantum ini jadi ini bukan
pilihan yang bagus yang bisa kita lakukan sebagai gantinya adalah menggunakan quantum circuit yang ditunjukkan di layar di sini di mana kita memasukkan state yang sudah di-encode
ke tiga qubit teratas pada dasarnya yang dilakukan circuit adalah menghitung paritas dari
state basis standar untuk dua qubit teratas maupun untuk dua qubit terbawah dari encoding dan ini akan mengungkapkan
lokasi bit flip khususnya dalam kasus ini kita akan mendapatkan hasil satu untuk kedua pemeriksaan paritas ini dan dari
informasi tersebut kita bisa menyimpulkan bahwa bit di tengah berbeda dari dua lainnya jadi itulah yang jelas
terbalik dan yang penting ini tidak menyebabkan state runtuh jadi sekarang kita punya kesempatan untuk mencoba mengoreksi bit
flip ini agar pada akhirnya kita bisa mendekode dan mendapatkan kembali state asli kita kita akan kembali ke koreksi
sebentar lagi tapi pertama mari kita pertimbangkan sebentar kemungkinan lain untuk bit flip error jika sebaliknya bit flip error
terjadi pada qubit bawah atau kiri maka kita akan mendapatkan hasil satu nol dibaca dari bawah ke atas dan lagi
state tidak akan berubah dan jika bit flip terjadi pada qubit teratas maka outputnya akan
01 dan sekali lagi state tidak berubah dan ngomong-ngomong jika tidak ada
bit flip error sama sekali maka hasil pengukuran adalah 00 dan sekali lagi state keluar tidak berubah
jadi mari kita rangkum semua ini dalam bentuk tabel di mana kita daftarkan masing-masing kemungkinan state yang kita dapatkan dari paling banyak satu bit flip, hasil
pengukuran yang kita sebut sebagai syndrome dalam konteks koreksi error dan koreksi yang perlu kita buat untuk mendapatkan kembali
encoding asli jika tidak ada error syndrome adalah 00 dan tidak perlu dilakukan apa-apa untuk memperbaiki
state jika qubit bawah atau paling kiri mengalami bit flip syndrome adalah 10 dan koreksi yang tepat
adalah menerapkan x gate pada qubit bawah atau paling kiri dan dua kasus lainnya adalah
serupa jadi jika kita menerapkan koreksi yang tepat berdasarkan syndrome maka kita pasti akan mendapatkan kembali encoding asli
dalam keempat kasus sekali lagi kita hanya mempertimbangkan kemungkinan bahwa paling banyak satu bit
flip error terjadi ini tidak akan bekerja dengan benar jika dua atau tiga bit terbalik dan kita juga belum mempertimbangkan
kemungkinan error lain sekarang mari kita pertimbangkan jenis error yang berbeda dalam seting quantum bit
flip error bukan satu-satunya error yang perlu kita khawatirkan misalnya kita juga harus khawatir tentang phase flip
error atau singkatnya phase flip yang digambarkan oleh Z gate atau setara poly Z
operasi sayangnya kode repetisi tiga-bit sama sekali gagal mendeteksi phase flip misalnya misalkan kita
meng-encode sebuah qubit menggunakan kode repetisi 3-bit seperti sebelumnya dan phase flip error terjadi pada
qubit di tengah kita akan mendapatkan state yang ditunjukkan di layar yang persis sama dengan encoding yang akan kita dapatkan jika
phase flip terjadi pada qubit asli sebelum kita meng-encode dan jadi jika kita melakukan
circuit yang sama seperti sebelumnya untuk mencoba mendeteksi error kita akan mendapatkan syndrome 00 yang salah mengartikan bahwa tidak ada error yang terjadi
jadi kode repetisi 3 bit bekerja untuk paling banyak satu bit flip error tapi gagal mendeteksi phase flip error bahkan
sebenarnya membuat keadaan lebih buruk dalam beberapa hal karena sekarang kita punya tiga kali lebih banyak qubit yang berpotensi mengalami phase flip
error kita sudah mengamati bahwa kode repetisi tiga-bit sama sekali tidak sadar terhadap phase flip error jadi tampaknya
tidak terlalu membantu untuk menangani jenis error ini tapi sebenarnya kita bisa memodifikasi kode repetisi tiga-bit agar ia
bisa mendeteksi phase flip error dan saya akan menjelaskan sekarang bagaimana ini bisa dilakukan berikut adalah circuit asli untuk
meng-encode qubit menggunakan kode repetisi 3-bit dan cara kita memodifikasinya sangat sederhana kita hanya menerapkan
Hadamard gate ke setiap qubit dari encoding Hadamard gate mengubah state nol menjadi state plus dan state satu
menjadi state minus sehingga efek bersihnya adalah kita mendapatkan state yang ditunjukkan di layar di mana ket
plus plus plus dan ket minus minus minus adalah notasi singkat untuk tensor dari tiga state plus atau tiga state minus
phase flip error atau dengan kata lain z gate mengubah state plus menjadi state minus dan state minus menjadi
state plus jadi encoding ini akan berguna untuk mendeteksi dan mengoreksi phase flip error dan untuk melakukan itu kita bisa
memodifikasi circuit deteksi error sebelumnya dengan cara berikut berikut adalah circuit dari sebelumnya dan yang akan kita lakukan adalah
hanya menempatkan Hadamard gate di awal dan akhir seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar
idenya sangat sederhana tiga Hadamard gate pertama mengubah state plus dan minus kembali menjadi state nol dan satu pemeriksaan
paritas yang sama seperti sebelumnya berlangsung dan kemudian lapisan Hadamard gate kedua membawa kita kembali ke
encoding cara lain untuk memikirkan ini adalah bahwa kita pada dasarnya hanya mengubah phase flip error menjadi bit flip error dengan mengkonjugasi menggunakan operasi Hadamard
ngomong-ngomong kita bisa menyederhanakan circuit sedikit circuit ini sepenuhnya setara
dan kamu bisa memeriksa ini sendiri jika kamu mau jadi jika kita memasukkan qubit yang sudah di-encode ke circuit ini dengan asumsi
tidak ada phase flip error yang terjadi kita mendapatkan syndrome 00 yang menunjukkan bahwa tidak ada phase flip
error dan jika kita memang memiliki phase flip error pada qubit teratas katakanlah maka plus dan minus paling kanan terbalik
dan itu menghasilkan syndrome error yang berbeda yaitu 01 dalam kasus ini yang mengidentifikasi lokasi phase flip sama seperti
yang kita miliki untuk bit flip dan kemudian kita bisa mengoreksinya dengan menerapkan z gate pada qubit teratas dan situasinya
serupa untuk phase flip error pada salah satu dari dua qubit lainnya jadi kita sebenarnya bisa mendeteksi dan
mengoreksi hingga satu phase flip error menggunakan kode ini tapi sayangnya seperti yang mungkin sudah kamu duga kita sekarang tidak lagi bisa
mengoreksi bit flip error namun tidak perlu khawatir karena kita sebenarnya bisa menggabungkan dua kode ini
bersama-sama untuk mendapatkan kode yang bisa mengoreksi baik bit flip maupun phase flip error dan bahkan akan bisa
mengoreksi untuk sembarang error pada satu qubit sudah saatnya untuk membahas 9 qubit Shore code yang merupakan kode
koreksi error Quantum yang bisa kita dapatkan dengan menggabungkan dua kode yang baru saja kita lihat yaitu kode repetisi tiga bit
yang memungkinkan kita untuk mengoreksi satu bit flip error dan versi modifikasi dari kode tersebut yang memungkinkan kita untuk mengoreksi satu phase flip
error untuk lebih tepatnya 9 qubit Shore code adalah kode yang kita dapatkan dengan menyambungkan dua kode yang berarti
kita pertama menerapkan satu encoding yang meng-encode satu qubit menjadi tiga dan kemudian kita menerapkan encoding lain pada masing-masing dari
tiga qubit tersebut secara terpisah sehingga kita mendapatkan total sembilan qubit kita bisa mengekspresikan ini dalam bentuk
diagram circuit sebagai berikut pertama kita akan menerapkan versi modifikasi dari kode repetisi 3-bit
yang mendeteksi phase flip error dan kemudian kita akan meng-encode masing-masing dari qubit yang dihasilkan secara independen menggunakan kode repetisi
3-bit asli jadi jika kita mengecilkan circuit ini sedikit untuk membuat lebih banyak ruang kita bisa
menentukan kode dalam istilah yang agak berbeda dengan menggambarkan bagaimana dua state basis standar untuk qubit asli kita
di-encode dan begitu kita mengetahui ini kita bisa menentukan dengan linieritas bagaimana vektor state qubit yang sembarang
di-encode jadi itulah 9 qubit Shore code dan idenya adalah bahwa salah satu kode memungkinkan kita untuk mengoreksi phase flip
error dan kode lainnya memungkinkan kita untuk mengoreksi bit flip error dan seperti yang akan kita lihat itu sebenarnya akan menyiratkan bahwa kita bisa
mengoreksi error sembarang pada satu qubit sekarang mari kita lihat bagaimana kita bisa mendeteksi dan mengoreksi error menggunakan 9 qubit
Shore code mulai dengan bit flip error yang juga disebut X error berikut adalah circuit yang melakukan
encoding dan hanya untuk memudahkan pembicaraan kita akan menganggap sembilan qubit yang kita dapatkan dari kode ini sebagai
dikelompokkan menjadi tiga blok tiga qubit di mana setiap blok mewakili encoding yang kita dapatkan dari menerapkan
langkah encoding kedua yaitu kode repetisi 3-bit biasa yang disebut inner code dalam
konteks ini sedangkan outer code adalah kode yang digunakan untuk langkah encoding pertama yang dalam hal ini adalah versi modifikasi
dari kode repetisi tiga-bit yang bekerja untuk phase flip error untuk mengoreksi bit flip error kita bisa
cukup memperlakukan setiap blok secara terpisah setiap blok adalah encoding qubit menggunakan kode repetisi tiga-bit
dan kode itu melindungi terhadap bit flip error misalkan pertama-tama sebuah X error terjadi pada salah satu qubit
seperti qubit di tengah di blok tengah jika kita secara independen memeriksa setiap blok untuk bit flip error dan
mengoreksi setiap error yang kita temukan maka error ini akan dikoreksi dan encoding asli akan
dipulihkan bahkan kita bisa memiliki beberapa X error dan tetap mengoreksinya dengan cara ini asalkan error-error tersebut berada di
blok yang terpisah jika kita memiliki dua atau tiga X error dalam satu blok kita akan kesulitan tapi
selama ada paling banyak satu X error per blok inner code akan menangkapnya dan kita akan bisa memulihkan encoded state asli
jadi mengoreksi bit flip error adalah masalah yang cukup sederhana untuk kode ini kita juga perlu mempertimbangkan phase flip error
atau dengan kata lain Z error kali ini tidak begitu jelas apa yang harus kita lakukan karena outer code adalah yang
mengoreksi phase flip error tapi kita tidak bisa langsung mendeteksi dan mengoreksinya karena inner code entah bagaimana
menghalangi tapi kita akan segera melihat cara melakukan ini untuk lebih memahami bagaimana X dan Z
error bekerja dan efek yang mereka miliki dalam quantum circuit akan sangat membantu untuk mengamati beberapa hubungan sederhana antara error-error ini dan
C not gate dan ini juga akan berguna dalam pelajaran berikutnya pertama mari kita mulai dengan X error
atau X gate dan bagaimana mereka berhubungan dengan C not gate jika kita menerapkan X gate pada
target qubit dari C not dan kemudian menerapkan C not itu setara dengan menukar urutan dan melakukan C not
terlebih dahulu di sisi lain jika kita menerapkan x gate pada control qubit dari C not dan kemudian menerapkan C not kita tidak bisa hanya
menukar urutan tapi sebagai gantinya kita harus menerapkan x gate pada kedua qubit dan kamu bisa memeriksa semua hubungan ini
sendiri jika mau dengan memikirkan apa yang terjadi pada state basis standar misalnya situasinya serupa untuk Z
error kecuali bahwa peran control dan target qubit bertukar khususnya jika kita melakukan
z gate pada control qubit dari C not dan kemudian melakukan C not maka itu memiliki efek yang sama dengan melakukan
z gate setelah C not tapi jika kita melakukan z gate pada target qubit sebagai gantinya maka itu
setara dengan pertama melakukan C not dan kemudian menerapkan z gate pada kedua qubit dan akhirnya semua
hubungan ini simetris dalam artian bahwa kita selalu bisa menukar urutan gate di kedua sisi setiap persamaan
yang setara dengan mengambil invers atau transpos konjugat dari kedua sisi mengingat bahwa x z dan C not
gate semuanya merupakan invers dari diri mereka sendiri sekarang mari kita pertimbangkan phase flip error dan bagaimana kita bisa mendeteksi dan mengoreksi
mereka menggunakan 9 qubit Shore code berikut adalah circuit encoding kita dan kita akan terus menganggap sembilan
qubit yang digunakan dalam encoding dikelompokkan menjadi tiga blok tiga qubit misalkan Z error terjadi pada
salah satu qubit seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini menggunakan apa yang baru saja kita amati tentang Z
gate dan C not gate itu setara dengan dua Z error sebelum C not satu pada
control dan satu pada target qubit dan error-error ini kebetulan komut dengan C not lain di blok sehingga kita
bisa menukar urutan dan berikut adalah yang kita dapatkan Z error yang lebih rendah tidak melakukan apa-apa karena ia beraksi pada state nol
dan kita bisa menggeser semuanya dan mendapatkan diagram ini jadi apa yang kita temukan adalah bahwa Z error di suatu tempat dalam
blok tengah setara dengan Z error yang terjadi pada qubit tengah sebelum fase encoding kedua dan
kamu bisa bernalar dengan cara yang persis sama untuk Z error pada qubit mana pun phase flip pada qubit mana pun dalam sebuah blok
setara dengan phase flip pada qubit yang sesuai sebelum inner encoding dan itu sebenarnya cukup mudah dan intuitif jika kamu
memikirkan bagaimana Z error mempengaruhi kode repetisi tiga-bit jadi salah satu opsi untuk menangani Z
error adalah mendekode inner code dan kemudian mendeteksi dan mengoreksi Z error menggunakan outer code yaitu versi modifikasi
dari kode repetisi 3-bit yang bisa mengoreksi Z error jadi itu mengoreksi Z error kita dan
kita bisa re-encode dengan inner code jika kita mau melakukan itu kita juga bisa mengoreksi Z error di
tempat begitu saja tanpa harus mendekode dan kemudian re-encoding dan itu cukup sederhana tapi untuk menjelaskan cara kita
melakukan itu kita butuh sedikit lebih banyak ruang misalkan kita mendekode inner code
dan kemudian kita menghitung syndrome untuk outer code menggunakan metode yang sama seperti sebelumnya di mana kita hanya melibatkan tiga qubit dari outer code dan
kemudian kita re-encode kita bisa menyederhanakan semua C not ini sedikit dan sebenarnya
kita bisa menggunakan hubungan antara not gate dan C not gate yang baru saja kita amati beberapa saat lalu untuk membantu dengan
tugas itu dan dengan melakukan ini kita bisa menghemat empat C not dan inilah circuit yang kita dapatkan jika Z error telah terjadi pada salah satu
qubit apa yang syndrome katakan kepada kita sekarang bukan qubit mana yang mengalami Z error tapi blok mana Z error
terjadi tapi tidak apa-apa karena kita tahu bahwa tidak masalah qubit mana dalam satu blok yang mengalami Z error
efeknya sama untuk ketiga qubit dalam blok tersebut dan jadi kita sebenarnya bisa mengoreksi Z error dengan menerapkan z gate pada salah satu
qubit dalam blok tersebut ini ngomong-ngomong adalah contoh dari apa yang disebut degenerasi dalam kode
koreksi error di mana kita tidak secara unik mengidentifikasi error tertentu tapi kita bisa mengoreksinya pula akhirnya misalkan baik
bit flip maupun phase flip error terjadi mungkin pada qubit yang sama misalnya misalkan
bit flip dan phase flip error terjadi pada qubit ini di sini ternyata error-error ini bisa
dideteksi dan dikoreksi secara independen sepenuhnya dan sebenarnya tidak masalah apakah kita mengoreksi setiap blok untuk
bit flip terlebih dahulu dan kemudian mengoreksi phase flip atau jika kita melakukannya sebaliknya untuk melihat ini pertama-tama mari kita amati
bahwa urutan error-error ini tidak masalah jadi kita bisa membaliknya jika mau alasan untuk itu bukan karena
x dan z komut karena mereka tidak x * Z sama dengan negatif Z * X tapi
faktor negatif 1 tidak memiliki efek dalam situasi ini karena itu adalah global phase kita sekarang bisa memindahkan Z error sama seperti
sebelumnya dan pada titik ini sudah jelas bahwa jika kita pertama mengoreksi setiap blok untuk X error dan kemudian kita mengoreksi
untuk Z error kita akan mengoreksi kedua error tersebut sebagai alternatif jika karena suatu alasan
kita memutuskan untuk mengoreksi Z error terlebih dahulu kita bisa melakukan itu dan X error sama sekali tidak memiliki efek dalam proses tersebut
itu harus benar karena pertama X error komut dengan setiap gate dalam circuit yang menghitung
syndrome untuk outer code dan kedua urutan antara X error dan z gate yang kita terapkan untuk membuat
koreksi tidak masalah sama seperti yang kita argumentasikan ketika z gate adalah sebuah error jadi itu memungkinkan koreksi dari Z
error dan kemudian kita bisa mengoreksi setiap blok untuk menghilangkan X error jadi apa yang kita argumentasikan adalah bahwa kita
bisa mengoreksi X error Z error atau keduanya pada salah satu qubit menggunakan kode ini
sebenarnya kita bisa mengoreksi lebih banyak error dari itu seperti beberapa X error selama mereka jatuh ke blok yang berbeda
atau beberapa Z error selama paling banyak satu blok mendapatkan jumlah ganjil dari mereka tapi ke depannya yang paling relevan
adalah bahwa kita bisa mengoreksi X error Z error atau keduanya pada satu qubit mana pun dan di bagian terakhir pelajaran
kita akan melihat bagaimana ini sebenarnya cukup untuk menyimpulkan bahwa kode ini bisa mengoreksi error sembarang pada satu qubit mana pun
sebelum kita beralih ke bagian terakhir pelajaran di mana kita akan mempertimbangkan error Quantum yang sembarang kita akan sebentar
mempertimbangkan performa kode Shore N qubit ketika error yang diwakili oleh matriks poly terjadi secara acak pada
qubit untuk lebih konkret mari kita pertimbangkan model noise sederhana di mana error terjadi secara independen pada qubit
dengan setiap qubit mengalami error dengan probabilitas p dan tanpa korelasi antara error pada qubit yang berbeda
skenario terburuk untuk 9 qubit Shore code adalah bahwa y error atau dengan kata lain baik X error maupun Z
error terjadi pada setiap qubit yang terpengaruh dan kita akan mengasumsikan skenario terburuk ini hanya untuk mendapatkan batas
pada performa kode tapi kamu juga bisa mempertimbangkan misalnya bahwa tiga poly error sama-sama
mungkin terjadi sekarang misalkan Q adalah qubit dalam state tertentu yang ingin kita lindungi dari error dan bayangkan bahwa
kita punya opsi untuk menggunakan 9 qubit Shore code haruskah kita menggunakannya jawabannya belum tentu
ya karena jika ada terlalu banyak noise atau dengan kata lain p terlalu besar menggunakan Shore code bisa sebenarnya memperburuk keadaan
sama seperti yang kita miliki untuk kode repetisi ketika p lebih besar dari 1/2 tapi jika p cukup kecil maka
jawabannya adalah ya kita harus menggunakan kode jadi mari kita lihat mengapa ini demikian dan apa artinya p terlalu besar atau cukup kecil
untuk kode ini Shore code bisa mengoreksi sembarang poly error pada satu qubit dan dalam skenario terburuk
di mana poly error adalah y error ini berarti bahwa kode berhasil melindungi Q dengan probabilitas yang diberikan oleh
ekspresi yang ditunjukkan di layar khususnya kode berhasil ketika tidak ada error dan itu terjadi
dengan probabilitas 1 minus p ^ 9 karena ada sembilan qubit yang masing-masing harus tidak terpengaruh dan berhasil ketika ada
tepat satu error dan mengingat bahwa ada sembilan qubit yang berbeda yang kemungkinan bisa terpengaruh ini terjadi dengan probabilitas 9 * P * 1 - p ^ 8
di sisi lain jika kita tidak repot-repot menggunakan kode satu-satunya qubit kita tidak akan terpengaruh oleh error dengan
probabilitas satu minus P jadi kode hanya membantu ketika probabilitas pertama lebih besar dari yang kedua
karena ekspresi-ekspresi ini mewakili probabilitas sukses kita dalam dua kasus ketika kita menggunakan kode dan ketika kita
tidak berikut adalah plot dari dua fungsi ini untuk nilai p yang kecil dan kita menemukan bahwa titik break even terjadi pada
sekitar 3 dan 3/4 persen jadi jika p lebih kecil dari nilai ini maka kode
membantu pada titik break even probabilitasnya sama jadi kita hanya membuang waktu bersama 8 qubit jika
kita menggunakan kode tapi selain itu tidak ada salahnya dan di luar titik itu kita sama sekali tidak boleh menggunakan kode ini
karena itu sebenarnya meningkatkan kemungkinan error pada qubit yang sudah di-encode yang biasanya kita sebut sebagai
logical qubit dalam konteks ini dan itu terjadi hanya karena kemungkinan dua atau lebih error pada sembilan qubit
lebih besar dari kemungkinan satu error pada satu qubit untuk nilai p dalam rentang ini 3 dan 3/4% mungkin tidak terlihat sangat
bagus terutama dibandingkan dengan 50% yang merupakan titik break even analog untuk kode repetisi tiga-bit untuk
informasi klasik tapi lebih sulit untuk melindungi informasi Quantum dan terlebih lagi meskipun
kode ini mewakili penemuan yang brilian sebagai kode koreksi error Quantum pertama yang sangat bagus untuk tujuan pedagogis faktanya
adalah bahwa ini tidak terlalu bagus sebagai kode dalam istilah praktis sejauh ini kita sudah mempertimbangkan X error
dan Z error dalam konteks 9 qubit Shore code sekarang mari kita pertimbangkan error arbitrary
mulai pertama-tama dengan error uniter jadi misalnya error semacam itu bisa bersesuaian dengan rotasi yang sangat kecil
dari bloch sphere kemungkinan mewakili error yang terjadi oleh gate yang tidak sempurna misalnya
atau bisa jadi operasi uniter lainnya pada qubit dan tidak selalu sesuatu yang dekat dengan operasi identitas
mungkin tampak seperti mengoreksi error semacam itu itu sulit ada tak terhingga banyak kemungkinan error seperti
ini dan tidak terbayangkan bahwa kita entah bagaimana bisa mengidentifikasi dengan tepat apa error itu dan kemudian membatalkannya tapi kita
sebenarnya tidak perlu melakukan sesuatu yang berbeda dari apa yang sudah kita bahas selama kita bisa mengoreksi bit flip phase flip atau keduanya maka kita
akan berhasil mengoreksi error uniter single qubit yang sembarang dan saya akan menjelaskan sekarang mengapa begitu
pertama-tama seperti semua matriks 2x2 kita bisa mengekspresikan matriks uniter arbitrary
yang mewakili error pada satu qubit sebagai kombinasi linier dari empat matriks poly termasuk matriks identitas
dan ngomong-ngomong seperti yang mungkin sudah kamu perhatikan saya menggunakan huruf kapital X Y dan Z untuk menyebut matriks poly non-identitas
dan saya akan terus melakukan itu untuk sisa seri ini itu konvensional dalam quantum error correction dan juga membuat
sesuatu sedikit lebih mudah dibaca dalam konteks ini juga akan berguna untuk menggunakan subskrip untuk menunjukkan
qubit mana operasi uniter qubit tertentu beraksi jadi misalnya jika kita menggunakan konvensi penomoran qubit
Qiskit yang dimulai dari qubit nol di kanan maka kita memiliki ekspresi yang ditunjukkan di layar untuk
berbagai operasi uniter pada qubit tunggal di mana dalam setiap kasus kita mentensor matriks uniter dengan matriks identitas
pada setiap qubit lainnya jadi khususnya kita bisa mengekspresikan UK yang artinya U diterapkan pada qubit K sebagai
kombinasi linier yang sama seperti sebelumnya kecuali bahwa setiap matriks poly diterapkan pada qubit K kita tidak perlu repot-repot dengan
subskrip untuk identitas ngomong-ngomong pemahaman di sini adalah bahwa ini adalah identitas pada semua
qubit sekarang misalkan S adalah encoding 9 qubit dari sebuah state qubit jika error U terjadi pada
qubit k maka kita mendapatkan u k * s yang bisa kita ekspresikan sebagai kombinasi linier dari operasi poly yang beraksi pada S yang tentu saja
hanyalah s dalam kasus identitas pada titik ini akan sangat membantu untuk mengamati bahwa matriks poly y
sama dengan i * x * Z jadi kita bisa melakukan substitusi itu dalam
ekspresi kita jadi error ini telah terjadi dan sekarang misalkan kita mencoba mengoreksinya menggunakan prosedur yang sama seperti
sebelumnya langkah pertama adalah menghitung syndrome yang dalam kasus Shore code adalah 8 bit panjangnya dua bit untuk masing-masing dari
tiga kali kita menggunakan inner code ditambah dua bit tambahan untuk outer code tapi sebenarnya tidak terlalu penting kita bisa hanya menganggapnya sebagai
string panjang tetap tertentu berikut adalah deskripsi state yang kita dapatkan tepat sebelum pengukuran syndrome di mana masing-masing
syndrome adalah delapan bit apa pun yang kita dapatkan dari poly error yang sesuai perhatikan pada titik ini bahwa dua
sistem secara umum berkorelasi dan ini sebenarnya adalah kunci untuk membuat semua ini bekerja dengan mengukur syndrome apa yang
secara efektif kita lakukan adalah meruntuhkan state menjadi satu di mana salah satu dari empat operasi poly telah diterapkan pada
qubit K dari sigma dan kita akan mengetahui dari syndrome operasi poly mana itu jadi kita bisa mengoreksinya jika
diperlukan khususnya jika kita mengukur syndrome dan membuat koreksi yang tepat maka kita mendapatkan state dari
bentuk yang ditunjukkan di layar yang secara kritis adalah product state kita memiliki encoding asli yang tidak terkorupsi sebagai
faktor tensor kanan yang paling penting di sini dan di sebelah kiri kita memiliki density matrix s yang
menggambarkan syndrome error acak tapi tidak ada lagi korelasi dengan sistem yang kita pedulikan yaitu
yang ada di kanan karena error sudah dikoreksi pada titik ini kita bisa membuang syndrome qubit atau mereset mereka
jika kita ingin menggunakannya lagi dan itu sebenarnya cukup penting karena beginilah keacakan atau entropi
yang dihasilkan oleh error dihapus dari sistem dan begitulah cara kerja diskretisasi Error setidaknya untuk error uniter
pada intinya dengan mengukur syndrome kita secara efektif memproyeksikan error ke error yang digambarkan oleh
matriks poly pada pandangan pertama mungkin tampak terlalu bagus untuk menjadi kenyataan bahwa kita bisa mengoreksi error uniter yang sembarang
seperti ini bahkan error yang kecil dan hampir tidak terlihat sendirinya tapi yang penting untuk disadari di sini
adalah bahwa ini adalah error uniter pada satu qubit dan berdasarkan desain kode operasi qubit tunggal tidak bisa mengubah state
dari logical qubit yang sedang di-encode semua yang bisa ia lakukan adalah memindahkan state keluar dari ruang encoding yang valid
tapi kemudian koreksi membawanya kembali ke tempat semula akhirnya mari kita pertimbangkan apa yang terjadi
ketika error arbitrary yang tidak harus uniter terjadi pengaturannya sama seperti sebelumnya
kita telah meng-encode satu qubit menjadi 9 menggunakan Shore code dan error arbitrary yang diwakili oleh qubit channel
terjadi pada salah satu qubit seperti yang akan kita lihat segalanya akan bekerja dengan cara yang hampir sama
seperti untuk error uniter dan langkah pertama untuk memverifikasi ini adalah mempertimbangkan representasi Kraus dari error kita
apa yang bisa kita lakukan sekarang adalah mengikuti persis penalaran yang sama seperti untuk error uniter kecuali bahwa kita menerapkan penalaran itu
pada matriks Kraus daripada pada matriks uniter tunggal yang mewakili error
khususnya setiap matriks Kraus bisa diekspresikan sebagai kombinasi linier dari matriks poly dan ini memungkinkan kita untuk
mengekspresikan aksi dari error ini pada qubit K mana pun dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di sini di
layar yang kita lakukan di sini hanyalah mengembangkan matriks Kraus sebagai kombinasi linier dari matriks poly
jika kita kemudian menghitung dan mengukur syndrome error dan mengoreksi error yang terungkap kita akan mendapatkan
state yang serupa dengan yang kita miliki dalam kasus error uniter saya tidak akan membahas detailnya ini semuanya cukup mirip dengan kasus uniter
dan juga sedikit lebih berantakan untuk dituliskan tapi secara konseptual cukup
mudah saya harus menyebutkan bahwa ini semua digeneralisasi ke kode koreksi error Quantum lainnya termasuk kode yang bisa mengoreksi error pada beberapa
qubit dalam kasus seperti itu error pada beberapa qubit bisa diekspresikan sebagai kombinasi linier dari produk tensor dari matriks poly
dan bersesuaian koreksi yang berbeda kemungkinan syndrome akan menggambarkan koreksi yang dilakukan pada beberapa qubit bukan hanya satu
qubit tapi ide dasarnya persis sama sekali lagi dengan mengukur syndrome
kita secara efektif memproyeksikan atau meruntuhkan error ke satu set kemungkinan yang diskret yang diwakili oleh produk tensor
dari matriks poly dan dengan mengoreksi error-error tersebut artinya poly error kita bisa memulihkan encoded state asli
sementara keacakan apa pun yang dihasilkan dalam proses ini dipindahkan ke syndrome qubit yang kemudian bisa kita
buang atau reset yang sangat penting karena beginilah entropi yang dihasilkan oleh error dan pengukuran syndrome
dihapus dari sistem dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran di mana kita sudah mengambil pandangan pertama pada
Quantum error correction termasuk 9 qubit Shore code dan diskretisasi Error saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
pelajaran berikutnya di mana kita akan membahas stabilizer formalism yang memberi kita alat yang ampuh untuk menggambarkan dan
menganalisis kelas yang besar dan menarik dari kode koreksi error quantum termasuk yang menjadi kandidat menjanjikan untuk
komputer quantum sungguhan sampai jumpa lagi